I'm really struggling doing the coffee enema since I have a hard time lying down and getting
back up. Is that bad that I'm not doing that? Well, I understand, um, doing the coffee
enema's the proper way, quote unquote, is that your lie down, lay it on one side and lay it
on back under your back, lay it and you're going to get up and go to the bathroom, but it's just
it can be a mess, right? And it can be difficult getting up and off the floor and off the bed
and then you know, all this kind of stuff. And guess what happens when things are difficult,
we tend not to do them, right? That's why in your on the bedversight, I posted Dr. Cutters easy
peasy ways to do coffee animals where you're just you're not doing it where you're lying down,
you could do it in the shower, you could leave your enema made hanging in the shower,
you could do it in the shower while you're standing and then step out to avoid and then step back
into the shower, clean off any mess you have and you're good to go. And then guess what,
it's easy to do. And you're 10, you're going to 10 to continue to do something that's easy to do.
And again, you know, are you effectively stimulating the vagal nerve doing it that way?
If you talk to some die hard coffee enema people that say, no, you're going to do it the right way.
Why? Because this is the way we're taught to do it from way back when in the early 1900s.
Okay? But you really think of physiology. You're just trying to get the caffeine up into your rectum
to affect where the vagal nerve surfaces in your rectum. I think you can do that standing up
as well as you do that lying down. So now I know there may be people that comment,
no, I try to that way. And I know that I get better effect if I lie down. Well,
then go ahead and continue to lie down. But for the 90% of us who that's more difficult to do
and you're quite honestly just not going to do it. If you're going to have to do it that way,
I'm the first one raising my hand there. I did it the easy,
peasy way all the times that I've ever done coffee enema. And guess what, I think I had just as good
of effect. You're trying to stimulate the vagal nerve, cranial nerve tend in the rectum.
That is your parasympathetic stimulation. There's only a few places that you can stimulate
the parasympathetic system externally. What is in your ear? It's very difficult to find that spot
and what is in your in your rectum. And it's easy to get that spot using coffee enema as your
stimulant. So the whole purpose of a coffee enema is to stimulate your parasympathetic nervous
system which controls rest and relaxation for your heart. It will decrease blood pressure. It'll
calm you. It'll calm your brain. It'll decrease inflammation of your brain. It'll stimulate your
immune system. It'll stimulate your detoxification pathways. So all these great benefits of your
stimulating your parasympathetics. And don't forget, my blog posted video on other ways that
you can stimulate parasympathetics. Just search sympathetic stimulants parasympathetic
website. I have that information also on the membership site and on some of the courses.
And it gives you functional neurology
helps on how to stimulate the parasympathetics. And some functional neurology helps
how to calm the sympathetic or the sympathetic are housed in a part of the midbrain called the
messencephalon. So I think that I titled that paper how to calm the messencephalon. So and then
the other paper is how to stimulate the vagal urn. So look at those. Some of them seem really kind of
weird, but they're straight neurology. So they can be very helpful. They can be very helpful
with anxiety. I know a lot of people with serious diseases have a, you know, have an issue with
anxiety. And a lot of people anxiety is the serious disease that they have an issue with. You know,
we're selling in this country more at any press incident to anxiety medications than anything on
the planet. And if we could just calm our messencephalon and stimulate our parasympathetic
system, we would be so far ahead. So don't take for granted the the simpleness of those things.
And misunderstand that they're not extremely powerful because they are. They're extremely powerful.
So I challenge you to to not to overlook those things. So look at that blog post